what you're watching is the initial
planning of a terror attack 18 year old
Matthew King walks past police officers
before taking a photo of them and
posting it on social media with the
caption Target acquired here he is
checking out an army barracks
prosecutors said he wanted to kill on
duty police or military personnel he
also looked into traveling to Syria to
join Isis Matthew King had converted to
Islam he'd been in trouble at school and
had been expelled initially his behavior
seemed to improve with his new focus on
religion but everything changed when
covid hit and there were National
lockdowns
it was during this time when he was
isolated that he became radicalized
online it is clear that you are Someone
Who develops an entrenched islamist
extremist mindset extreme anti-western
views and that you intended to commit
terrorist acts both in UK and overseas
these are some of the items King
purchased he also tried to set up an
account needed to buy a knife online
it's tempting to think he didn't pose a
lot of danger given that this was a
probably a low sophistication terrorist
attack using bladed instruments however
this is a really serious threat to the
public and to colleagues and to the Army
and really for me this was an imminent
terrorist attack and we needed to
disrupt it
the police received concern calls about
King's Behavior including from his own
mother who was so worried she reported
him to the counter-terrorism program
prevent and after one of his Sinister
reconnaissance missions he was arrested
although it was King's family who put
him on the police's radar in a letter to
the judge they said they'll always
support him it is thanks to them that
his desire to kill never became a
reality Becky Cottrell Sky News at the
Old Bailey